Rock radroaches can't test what is that
holes got plenty of stopping power now
uh-huh I'm not sure might be right back
thicker walls can beat the whole only
thing I've ever seen survived a Queen's
acid so you gather up a bunch of the
camp then I'll reinforce okay my earlier
best of luck sure okay helper each
straight right that's our gotta be
[ __ ] [ __ ] me they love putting it
places where it's like really hard to
get to ah yes
you
in a disgusting
like look at this thing ok disgusting
vaccinated kids okay like cheese okay oh
yeah
[ __ ] running again cuz that's all
this DLC yes it's a run it send me a
lighter [ __ ] yeah it's a run it
cellulite legs up [ __ ] Yeah right
it's the water now we're getting
attacked by now it's a let's say
okay is that bad boy got to have to take
a swing at me I canceled
um some [ __ ] text hmm ok connect that
[ __ ] you like pasting take a little
taste for daddy I'll taste your daddy
watching ring the [ __ ] is that what is
that
hey get a pocket dying [ __ ] dying
hey says okay
okay thank you that's a big tree I had
class am I
disgusting all right oh ok I got one oh
Jesus another [ __ ] gonna help me out
what the [ __ ] is a kill clock sir
Shaq
can't kill the sketch okay let's get the
[ __ ] out of here
you
okay where is this a [ __ ]
cutting hair pisses is a dirty job the
pay will be worth it I got your my
earlier carapace is finally it's done
everything that can be welded duct tape
or smells like I can find okay enjoy the
break I wonder how long before something
didn't care my dicks out for her Amish